en enero de 2020 menos de 100 personas
habían muerto oficialmente por kobe 19
pero el doctor seth berkley el que se
diga va al programa que vacuna a niños
en todo el mundo ya estaba ideado un
plan su objetivo era garantizar que los
países más pobres dispusieran de vacunas
en el caso de que hubiera una campaña de
vacunación global fue en septiembre de
2020 cuando su iniciativa se hizo
realidad y 156 países se sumaron a ella
ahora casi todas las naciones del mundo
están a bordo esto significa que las
instalaciones de kóvacs están ahora
abiertas al negocio pero el modelo
kóvacs plagado de dificultades no ha
salido como estaba previsto hasta ahora
ha entregado poco más de 81 millones de
vacunas contra el hobbit 19 a 129
participantes de gabi muy lejos de su
objetivo de mayo de 238 millones algo
que se suma a las promesas incumplidas
los contratos no vinculantes y las
demandas problemáticas el suministro fue
un problema importante kóvacs hizo un
gran pedido al instituto de suero en
india
pero cuando la variante delta llegó al
país cesaron las exportaciones ya que
nueva delhi prefirió como otras naciones
vacunar primero a su población los
líderes mundiales aseguran que hay una
hoja de ruta de 50 mil millones de
dólares para vacunar a los países en
desarrollo algo que generaría unos 9
billones de dólares en rendimiento
económico la esperanza sigue siendo que
como las naciones ricas tendrán un
exceso de oferta los países en
desarrollo puedan ver un aumento los
envíos de kóvacs eeuu ha anunciado que
enviará 500 millones de dosis para el
mecanismo kóvacs paquete del que se
espera su último envío para la primera
mitad de 2022